[Music]
earlier this year a local pastor
survived after being
stabbed 21 times with a butcher knife
today the city of las vegas recognized
the care
umc staff provided to that pastor during
an appreciation event
hector mejia has the story doctors here
at university medical center performed
multiple surgeries that ultimately saved
the reverend's life
i got 21 stab wounds most of them can't
see their
torso look
face here on march 8 reverend russ
smethers was viciously attacked while at
home
he's now recovering while the person who
stabbed him 21 times is behind bars
smothers says he's still alive thanks to
the care he received here at umc
he's an associate pastor at abundant
peace church
appreciate what you've got it could be
gone tomorrow
and that goes for all across all
spectrums of everything
las vegas city councilwoman victoria
seaman brought the doctors who treated
the reverend
a recognition award on behalf of the
entire city
smothers thanks them too we appreciate
the
the recognition and we'll be here if you
need us
and the reverend has some therapy to go
through while all of his wounds continue
to heal reporting outside umc
hector mejia 8 news now